le fils national du film pourrait-il
ravir ce soir sa XIIIème statuette la
95e cérémonie des Oscars le film le
matelot volant et finaliste dans la
catégorie Meilleure court métrage
d'animation une nomination pour l'OMF
une fierté pour la nouvelle commissaire
qui souhaite que le fils continue
d'innover et de raconter des histoires
bien canadiennes j'ai rencontré Suzanne
gevremont dans un cinéma du centre-ville
d'Ottawa
Suzanne guévrement bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation au
théâtre au cinéma by Town
parlons d'abord de ce film que vous avez
en nomination aux Oscars à quel point
c'est important une nomination Oscars
77 nominations jusqu'à maintenant si on
gagne ça sera notre 13ème trophée alors
c'est important en ce sens que ça fait
rayonner l'ONF ça fait rayonner le film
nécessairement et bien sûr si on gagne
ça va donner comme un effet de levier
pour le faire pour le faire ce promener
un peu partout à travers à travers le
monde et de raconter une histoire qui
est vraiment canadienne par deux
cinéastes extraordinaires qui viennent
de Calgary mais l'histoire est plantée à
les fax effectivement c'est un effet de
levier pour le film c'est un effet de
levier pour l' ONF pour les deux je vous
dirais parce que c'est sûr que bon les
Oscars c'est le rendez-vous
cinématographique de la planète c'est
celui qui est le plus regardé c'est
celui qui a une très très grande
notoriété donc d'être reconnu par une
institution comme l'Académie
ça reconnaît que l'ONF a une longue
tradition notamment dans le cinéma
d'animation puis on est c'est sûr qu'on
va on va pouvoir faire du ménage avec ça
fait un peu plus trois mois maintenant
vous êtes que vous avez été une
mi-commissaire à l'Office national du
film quelles sont vos objectifs pour
l'ONF les objectifs ça va être de
continuer l'innovation de s'assurer que
notre mandat notre mission est bien
ancrée dans Qu'est-ce qu'on représente
donc de raconter des histoires
canadiennes au Canadien à l'ensemble de
du monde évidemment je vous parlais
d'innovation tout à l'heure ça va être
important de continuer d'innover parce
que c'est au cœur de notre de notre
mandat puis d’incuber une relève d'avoir
des talents émergents et d'être une
représentation des perspectives de
l'ensemble du Canada vous savez on est
une on dit une grande organisation on
est une grande petite organisation dans
un grand territoire
un énorme territoire avec une très belle
mission de représenter toute la
diversité ce jour quoi comme rôle l'OMF
dans le monde cinématographique canadien
qui n'est pas que l'ONF il y a beaucoup
de
vous voyez où votre niche à vous votre
rôle là-dedans mais on a on a une
mission particulière en ce sens que
quand on fait du documentaire on va
raconter des histoires qui qui sont pas
nécessairement intéressantes pour
d'autres milieux pour un producteur
privé exactement et puis ça ça fait
partie de notre rôle parce que on est là
pour raconter les histoires canadiennes
et on est là pour aller rejoindre le
public là où il est partout dans le pays
donc par exemple l'année dernière on a
fait 5000 projections partout dans
différentes communautés à travers le
pays producteur privé il y a pas le
temps il y a pas la capacité de faire ça
puis nous ça fait partie de notre mandat
d'aller rejoindre les gens où ils sont
et de leur raconter les histoires qui
qui sont pour eux quand je préparais
entrevue je parlais je parlais de l'OMF
à des plus jeunes la nouvelle génération
il y avait une espèce de mou à côté on
avait l'impression qu'il y avait une
perception côté un peu ringard là-dedans
est-ce que est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous sentez est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que vous devez on doit
toujours se réagir avec les jeunes
auditoires alors on a un mandat
d'éducation avec un grand E à l'ONF
puisse l'important puis on veut le
maintenir ce mandat mais c'est vrai que
les le comportement des jeunes et des
jeunes auditoires changent puis il faut
qu'on trouve des moyens d'aller
rejoindre ces jeunes là ce qu'on faisait
très très bien il y a certaines à
l'époque à une certaine époque tout à
fait je pense qu'il faut redoubler
d'efforts dans ce contexte là pour
s'engager avec une avec une jeunesse
puis de parler avec les professeurs de
parler avec et de de mettre à
disposition tout le contenu qu'on a de
fines documentaires pour faire pour
éduquer les jeunes en fait sur
sur notre beau pays est-ce que est-ce
qu'il y a un virage qui a été manqué un
moment donné quelque part là-dedans ou
est-ce qu'on a négligé un peu cette
filière là à un moment donné écoutez je
peux pas arriver à cette conclusion là
j'oserais pas dire ça parce qu'on a
vraiment beaucoup on continue à mettre
énormément d'efforts dans la filière
éducation mais je pense qu'il faut il
faut rester aux aguets puis il faut
continuer à intéresser les jeunes dans
leur comportement parce que les
comportements des auditoires ont changé
énormément on est plus nécessairement
assis devant la télévision à 8h le matin
non c'est ça parce que effectivement
vous êtes en compétition assez direct
avec des Netflix des apot TV des craives
vous vous positionnez comment dans cette
espèce d'écosystème
sur nos écrans intelligents on se
positionne comment mais c'est encore le
défi de dire qu'on va les rejoindre nos
auditoires là où on a besoin d'aller les
rejoindre donc c'est sûr que nous on n'a
pas un mandat de divertir c'est pas on
n'est pas un divertisseur à grand dans
le grand déploiement mais il faut qu'on
puisse être en mesure de dire bon ben
vous allez venir sur onf.ca vous allez
avoir accès à des contenus gratuits on
va regarder d'autres méthodes de de
diffusion parce qu'on est un diffuseur
alors nécessairement il faut falloir
qu'on fasse on a beaucoup d'initiatives
spécifiques comme je vous parlais de
5000 produits de projection à travers le
pays c'est énorme on rejoint une
population on a des millions de vues sur
notre site alors c'est c'est non
négligeable mais c'est sûr que c'est du
contenu qui est qui est spécifique puis
qui qui éduque finalement il y a des
membres du milieu cinématographiques au
Québécois qui associe parfois à temps ou
à raison le travail de l'ONF un peu a de
la propagande canadienne vous dites quoi
ces gens-là
c'est pas nécessairement négatif faut
faire attention la propagande n'a pas
été très positive on parlait d'unicité
canadienne on va pouvoir ça veut dire
quoi vivre au Canada aujourd'hui dans
toute sa diversité dans toutes ces
différences qu'est-ce que c'est vivre à
Edmonton versus vivre à Manton qu'est-ce
que c'est alors oui moi j'ai si on
utilise le mot propagande d'une manière
positive de communication et d'éducation
j'ai pas de problème avec ce terme-là
c'est pas c'est notre culture qu'on
promouvoir finalement l'ONF à la fin de
votre mandat le radar de quoi j'aimerais
ça qu'on continue à trouver des
nouvelles manières de raconter des
histoires au canadiens
j'aimerais ça qu'on
utilise les technologies au service de
raconter une histoire percutante qu'on
ait un impact qu'on soit pertinent et
que
qu'on soit innovant c'est je pense que
c'est ça que que qu'on explore comment
raconter de nouvelles histoires de
manière différente au Canadien merci
beaucoup merci